[upbeat rock music]
woman: Cloud Speech API
allows application developers
to use Google's best-in-class
speech recognition technology
for a simple API.
You can send audio data
directly to the cloud
from your application
and the API will respond
with a text transcription
of your audio.
Cloud Speech API uses the same
machine learning technology
we use for the advanced
voice recognition features
on Android devices, such as
voice search in the Google app
and voice typing
in Google Keyboard.
[phone chimes]
What's the weather in Tokyo?
digital female voice: It's
8 degrees and clear in Tokyo.
woman: The API supports
over 80 languages and provides
high recognition accuracy,
even in noisy environments.
We encapsulate sophisticated
speech recognition models
built on years
of Google research
with an easy-to-use API
for any app developer.
So any application
can now listen
and implement voice interactions
with their users
using the power
of cloud computing.
Let's see the Speech API
in action by calling it
directly from a Raspberry Pi
GoPiGo robot.
The bot can capture audio
through its microphone,
send it to the cloud,
and receive
the recognized text in response
in real time
with partial results returned
while the user is speaking.
Now let's see how it works.
Can you dance?
You can also specify
to the API what language
you would like to recognize.
[speaking Japanese]
[speaking Portuguese]
You can combine Speech API
with the other
Google Cloud APIs.
In our bot, we have combined it
with Vision API
to run OCR on an image of text.
Can you read this?
Speech API supports
both streaming recognition
and non-streaming recognition.
That means the API
is best suited not only
for real-time recognition,
like I demonstrated,
but also for batch recognition
use cases
such as transcribing voicemails,
podcasts, call center calls,
or processing
any stored voice data.
As a result, the Speech API
lets you add an interactive
and voice-activated interface
to your application
with the power
of Google Cloud Platform.
Please go to
cloud.google.com/speech/
for more details.